the gloves are finally off at the
shanghai motor show in april this year
toyota came out with its competitor
against tesla cars the first in a slew
of 15 new all-electric models toyota's
all-electric concept suv may launch by
2025. before then i'll be showing you
all the juicy details i get about the
car and examining if it can beat the
existing tesla models toyota's tesla
beta most of toyota's current ev sales
are hybrids powered by a combination of
battery and internal combustion engine
it's most famous for its prius launched
in 1997 and has been a bestseller among
environmentally conscious drivers
worldwide however it's always surprised
me that the company never really focused
on developing an all-electric
battery-powered vehicle even as they
watch tesla slowly take over the market
the new all-electric suv that toyota is
launching is called the bz-4x and it
will be its first foray into making a
fully electric vehicle the car will be
available to customers by the end of
2022 and will come in both front wheel
and all-wheel drive variants this car
definitely seems to be a direct response
to tesla which has been dominating the
electric car market for years now the
bz-4x has a range of 250 miles which is
on par with tesla's cars it also charges
pretty quickly with a fast charger
reaching 80 capacity in just 30 minutes
at this point it is worth pointing out
that toyota is also running an offer for
a free integration of the home power
module and the charging system for a
limited period i'm not sure how many
people will be able to avail this offer
but it is definitely a nice perk for the
first few buyers of the new car in terms
of design the bz-4x takes some
inspiration from tesla cars but still
looks very much like a toyota the front
end seems to be inspired by their new
corolla cross suv but instead of its
large traditional grille this car
features a small mesh panel that spans
the vehicle's width and the rest of the
front is covered with bodywork the air
intakes are also placed very tastefully
giving this car a futuristic look the
overall bodywork around the vehicle also
features sleek lines hard angles and
edges that give this suv an urban
utility vehicle feel keeping in line
with the car's futuristic design the
headlights are also slim and sporty the
tail light design is reminiscent of the
new prius model but here a single line
of leds wraps around the entire rear
hatch of the car which looks quite
remarkable to be honest the bz-4x is an
suv so it is slightly larger than a
tesla model x it's also wider and has a
longer wheelbase resulting in a more
comfortable ride the interior of the
bz4x is where toyota has really tried to
set itself apart from tesla the japanese
manufacturer says that the car has been
designed with relaxation in mind the
seats are made from a material that is
designed to reduce fatigue and the car
also has a zen mode which will help
passengers to relax before reaching
their destination features wise there is
a 7-inch gauge cluster behind the wheel
plus a larger infotainment screen in the
middle of the dashboard toyota has not
gone the tesla route of putting
everything behind a touchscreen so there
are physical buttons for vital in-car
features like climate control music
driving modes etc just like any other
road car another cool feature of the car
is its augmented reality heads up
display this is a first for any
production all-electric vehicle and will
allow drivers to see information about
their surroundings without taking their
eyes off the road the car also features
an advanced driver assistance system
that automatically handles lane changes
braking and acceleration obviously it
will not be anything close to tesla's
fsd but we knew that already maybe
toyota plans to develop an all-seeing ai
in the future to aid with fully
self-driving but i'm not privy to those
plans yet technology range and cost
technology wise there seems to be
nothing revolutionary about this car but
looking at the data sheets it does come
packed with all the updated tech
required for a well-performing
all-electric vehicle toyota will sell
the bz-4x in front and all-wheel drive
variants the front-wheel drive models
will have a 150 kilowatt motor with 201
horsepower and a top speed of 100 miles
an hour with 0 to 60 in 8.4 seconds
while the all-wheel drive models offer
dual 80 kilowatt motors boosting the
overall power to 214.5
brake horsepower and reducing the 0 to
60 time to 7.7 seconds all models of the
bz-4x will have a 71.4 kilowatt-hour
battery which comes in built with a
water cooling system to extend the
battery's life as long as possible
prolonged exposure to high temperatures
can speed up degradation and reduce the
battery capacity over time but
unfortunately heat is one of the
byproducts of charging which is
essential if you're planning to drive
beyond the car's typical range this
technology is nothing new as other
automakers have come up with ways to
keep their batteries cool during the
charging process as well for example
companies like renault blow cool air
over the battery while tesla uses a
custom coolant to keep temperatures down
however toyota seems to have opted for
the old-fashioned water cooling system
and claims that battery degradation will
be as little as 10 after 10 years or 150
000 miles of driving all new car models
will be equipped with a standard ccs
charging socket which offers up to a 6.6
kilowatt rate of charging from a level 2
ac charger according to toyota that will
recharge the car from low to full in
around 9 hours the front wheel drive
models can handle up to 150 kilowatt dc
rapid charging which toyota claims will
restore 80 percent of the car's power in
just 30 minutes the all-wheel drive
models can somewhat disappointingly only
handle 100 kilowatts dc charging
range-wise toyota has confirmed that the
front-wheel drive model will be able to
travel 252 miles on one charge as per
the epa standard the limited model has a
slightly lower range of 242 miles due to
its larger 20-inch wheels and the
all-wheel drive model offers even less
range because its dual motor
configuration is more power hungry which
means you'll get up to 228 miles out of
the car on one charge the limited
all-wheel drive offers 222 miles of
range per charge once again thanks to
the larger wheels now let's look at the
price of this new car toyota has been
pretty transparent about the costs of
the models so the bz4x's price will
start at 42 000 which will get you a
front-wheel drive xle version of the car
when it goes on sale sometime in spring
2022. a limited variant of the
four-wheel drive model will cost forty
six thousand seven hundred dollars
complete with larger wheels and design
modifications if you want an all-wheel
drive model you'll need to shell out
forty four thousand and eighty dollars
while a limited variant of that same
model will cost forty eight thousand
seven hundred and eighty dollars the
limited models will have larger wheels
unique color schemes and several design
choices like multi-led headlights chrome
accents and a lower grille with the
limited model you will also be able to
get a solar panel built onto the roof
which will offer some additional power
to the battery how much is anyone's
guess at this point it will likely
depend on where you live as well and if
other solar powered cars are anything to
go by it probably won't be more than a
few miles per hour at best so is it a
tesla beta this is the first question
that popped up when i saw the car i
guess the answer depends on your
definition of tesla beta if you compare
the bz4x with its closest tesla
counterpart the model x on pure
performance both cars are pretty much on
a level playing field regarding the
battery capacity power delivery and
range of course the model x's p110d and
100d models are far superior in
performance than even the top-end
all-wheel drive version of the bz-4x but
then those cars are almost twice as
expensive so yes when it comes to the
price this new all-electric toyota car
is definitely a tesla beater on the flip
side tesla's main appeal has always been
its cutting-edge fsd technology and the
strides that the company is making with
its fully self-driving beta are
genuinely insane so in that regard this
new toyota comes nowhere close to
beating the tesla models so all in all i
would say that just this new car in
itself will not be a tesla beater but
toyota's overall ev strategy can give
tesla a run for its money in the coming
years as i mentioned at the beginning of
this video the company plans to roll out
15 new cars in this segment by 2025
which is a lot of vehicles in a very
short period although not a whole lot is
known about those cars you can be sure
that these new cars will cover all
customer niches when it comes to evs but
unfortunately as it stands now tesla
cars are still beyond the reach of the
common man maybe they'll be able to
address that with their future 25 000
car but they are far from achieving that
on the other hand toyota has thrown down
the gauntlet the company is already
seeking to dominate this market and
provide an eevee solution addressing all
types of customer needs at all price
ranges and features so if tesla has
enjoyed very little competition in the
electric car market till now with
toyota's new entry that could all change
one thing is for sure the electric car
market is about to get a lot more
competitive let me know what you think
of toyota's first all-electric car do
you agree that the japanese car
manufacturer will be able to challenge
tesla's dominance in this market and if
you enjoyed this video there's more
click the card on the screen and i'll
see you there